et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
annie genevard bonjour ben joue beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes député du
doubs vice présidente de l'assemblée
nationale et vice présidente déléguée
des républicains et on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale et fabrice veysseyre donc
s'installeront leur fabrique bonjour aux
rien des journaux du groupe ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
dont le vôtre annie genevard les
républicains on commence en parlant
évidemment des républicains ça y est les
militants ont donc choisi ont donc
tranché ils choisiront leur candidat
tout seul plusieurs congrès le 4
décembre prochain vous qui voulez un
candidat de rassemblement n'êtes vous
pas en train d'envoyer le signal d'un
parti qui se rétrécit sur lui-même donc
pas du tout au contraire je pense qu'on
donne le visage d'un parti cohérent qui
sait être solide sur ses bases dont les
militants et les adhérents ont choisi
c'est la règle c'était votre clip aux
critiques c'était mon choix c'était mon
choix parce que j'ai toujours pensé que
la primaire était une machine à à
diviser et conformément à nos statuts
les adhérents tranché mais s'agissant
des centristes
évidemment je comprends leur déception
mais nous cheminerons ensemble comme
nous l'avons toujours fait à la
présidentielle et puis pendant un
quinquennat et puis au moment des
législatives donc ils savent très bien
que nous travaillerons ensemble comment
pourquoi pourquoi les centristes aurait
un candidat commun avec vous et vous
suivrait alors qu'ils n'ont pas leur mot
à dire dans la désignation d imaginer
que les républicains
participent à un congrès centriste bon
vous voyez ça va pas la force de
l'évidence non plus donc c'est que c'est
une proposition qui a été faite par les
centristes les républicains les
adhérents les républicains ont considéré
qu' il était plus clair dans décidée par
le même ce qui ne signifie pas qu'on
ferme la porte en aucune façon dans les
territoires étaient très loyaux au
m'hiri bien sûr mais bien sûr des
républicains mais mais mais
naturellement et ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas une non reconnaissance de leur
loyauté simplement on a des statuts
chaque partie à son mode de
fonctionnement on a voulu christian
jacob a voulu laisser les adhérents
parfaitement libres de leur choix et je
crois que le congrès elle mérite de
rassembler de conforter la famille c'est
la solidité de la base et après on ouvre
comme on l'a toujours fait hervé morin
est un compagnon d'une très grande
fidélité comme vous l'avait dit et cette
fidélité cette alliance a été fructueuse
regarder aux régionales
nous nous sommes mis d'accord dans les
régions qui étaient détenus par les
centristes et il ya eu aucune difficulté
et demain j'en suis convaincu il n'y
aura aucune difficulté à me
dire la porte n'est pas fermée on le
fait à ma merde ça veut dire qu'ils ne
seront associés de quelle manière laisse
mais ils seront associés bas ne serait
ce que sur les législatives vous savez
très bien que des discussions s'engagent
avec les partis amis puis il ya la
campagne présidentielle et puis elle
quinquennat et il y a un gouvernement
il ya une politique qui est conduite et
là les gouvernements de droite se sont
toujours ouverts aux centristes vous le
savez bien donc je pense que la pâte la
droite 1 qui draguent les centristes ya
aussi la droite de la majorité
présidentielle j'ai côtés d'emmanuel
mâcon du côté d'edouard philippe est ce
que vous craignez pas que les centristes
soient tentés de rejoindre la droite de
la majorité présidentielle
d'août et la politique est une affaire
duffy d'éviter la politique conduite par
emmanuel macron et ses gouvernements
successifs on la connaît on en a vu
toutes les limites moi j'ai entendu les
centristes critiquer sévèrement c'est de
cette politique donc après c'est une
question de cohérence quant à edouard
philippe bond il veut croire à son
destin c'est son droit
écoutez
l'ambition il al'ambition
finalement d'être le nouveau bayrou de
demain de pouvoir capter
le sang
écoutez je sais pas à vous d'apprécier
bayrou est on ne peut pas dire que
bayrou était à un fidèle de notre
famille politique et donc en ce sens
c'est ce qui nourrit la comparaison que
je fais avec lui bon je pense que
edouard philippe soutient emmanuel
macron et c'est normal il a été son
premier ministre et il a appliqué
scrupuleusement la politique était
exigée de lui donc sa mission et de
ramener le président vers un électorat
de droite mais les français ne sont pas
dupes de ces petites manoeuvres
électorales regardez ce qui s'est passé
aux régionales
où la république sommes en marche parti
au pouvoir a fait un score minable donc
les français sont attachés aussi à une
forme de clarté edouard filet pour
l'instant tente de s'autonomiser de
macron c'est assez
symptomatique
tout en jouant clairement sa loyauté en
jurant fidélité enfin en même temps il
crie son parti
donc voilà tout ça et finalement
s'apparente à de la cuisine politicienne
je pas sûr que les français beaucoup ça
vous évoquez des centristes l'instant
vous espérer les retrouver dans un
deuxième temps mais justement risque il
ne sera pas trop tard
oriane le disais c'est centriste là et
cherchent une voie cherche à exister
vous faisiez le parallèle entre edouard
philippe et françois bayrou qui n'a
jamais eu d'ailleurs réussir à être élue
et elle est pourtant a été toutefois
candidat
c'est quoi la bonne parade avec les
centristes ils ont pris l'un y compris
dans les dossiers conscription dont il
n'est pas question de parade il n'y a
pas de n'y a pas à parer à un danger au
contraire il y a à construire une union
et
les bons mois je pense que les
centristes sont sensibles au principe de
réalité ils savent que le premier parti
d'opposition
c'est l'air que nos destins sont liés
que la victoire et est au prix de
l'union et du rassemblement
il se fera en plusieurs temps c'est tout
le pari de christian jacob de construire
les choses de façon pierre après pierre
il ya déjà fallu reconstruire la famille
l'est républicain la rassembler les
reconduites qu'elle est reconstruite
tony g de beurre c'est oui moi je pense
qu'elle est elle est vraiment
aujourd'hui sur des bases reconstruction
ou une survie aujourd'hui prenant non je
ne parlerai absolument pas de survie je
vais vous donner plusieurs arguments qui
vous démontreront la vitalité de notre
formation politique
d'abord nous regagnons des adhérents je
pense qu'on terminera l'année à 100
mille adhérents
ski
double quasiment le score par rapport à
l'année dernière à la même date les les
dons reviennent nous avons gagné toutes
les élections nous avons un projet
complet cohérent
christian jacob a amené tout le monde
autour de la table bien sûr il ya des du
débat mais c'est normal on n'est pas
parti soviétique en débat entre nous
évidemment aujourd'hui que les réseaux
sociaux quand on débat entre nous on
n'est plus tout à fait entre nous mais
mais non c'est un parti vivant est
véritablement qui croit en son avenir
moi je pense que les français ils l'ont
dit d'ailleurs ne veulent pas du duo
annoncé je pense qu'on a réellement nos
chances parce que
le pays et le pays est fatigué à défaut
de l'avoir la présidentielle c'est de la
voir peut-être aux législatives
cette chance à moi je pense que on va
tenter notre chance au tirage et au
grattage si je veux dire
donc évidemment sauf que la
présidentielle parti il n'y a pas deux
il n'y a pas de chef incontesté il n'y a
pas de candidat
naturelle ou alors est-ce qu'il y en a
un pour vous de candidature elle est ce
qu'aujourd'hui en a un qui simple
s'ils avaient eu un candidat naturel il
se serait
naturellement imposée à tous c'est elle
que xavier bertrand qui semble avoir une
longueur d'avancé en location en croit
les sondages pour vous ce n'est pas le
candidat naturel il s'impose poserait
alors il y a ça ne vous a pas échappé
dans les enquêtes qui ont été conduites
effectivement xavier bertrand
et est en tête mais dans ce
périmètre là il ya d'autres candidats
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons opté pour cette procédure à
laquelle jacques bertrand ne dis pas
qu'ils ne participent aura quand même
été donné par estrosi sassone lors du
dernier bureau politique et un de ses
lieutenants a dit clairement que c'est
lui bertrand participerez au concret
c'est aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles
je préférais le congrès parce que tous
les candidats qui le souhaitent peuvent
concourir et veulent concourir donc là
on n'a pas un candidat en dehors du
processus et des candidats dans le crous
tous les candidats juste 11 août parce
qu'il y avait françois xavier bellamy
sur ce plateau à votre place et lui dit
qu'eric zemmour il ne voit pas
d'obstacle à ce qu'eric zemmour
participe là votre congrès est ce que
c'est le cas aussi pour vous paierez
xénon n'est pas encore officiellement
candidat
premièrement deuxièmement et régime on
n'a jamais dit qu'il souhaitait être
concourir ou au congrès
des républicains est ce que c'est le
dessin vont couvrir n'est pas le bon mot
mais participer au congrès c'est un
problème pour moi je ne vois pas selon
quelle cohérence et
eric zemmour est un homme intelligent et
cohérent donc je ne vois pas comment on
peut d'un côté
critiqué les républicains comme il le
fait et de l'autre vouloir participer à
leur congrès donc je ne vois je ne
verrai pas de cohérence à une telle
démarche c'est uniquement ça ou est ce
que vous dites ne partagent pas nos
valeurs ou alors il ya ce partage aux
valeurs et alors il faut avoir un
certain respect pour l'homme
ah mais moi je ne je pense que le
diaboliser est une erreur c'est
quelqu'un qui dont on partage les
constats ou qui partagent les nôtres
plus tôt dans ce sens là sur la question
les questions qu'ils évoquent de
souveraineté nationale or justement
c'est donc aucune difficulté à partager
avec lui ce constat maintenant santé des
valeurs communes avec les sur certains
points alors sur l'amour de la france
sur la souveraineté nationale sur bien
sûr sont des choses que nous défendons
aussi mais il ya un certain nombre de
choses sur lesquelles nous ne sommes pas
d'accord ses déclarations sur l'attentât
toulouse m'ont choqué celle sur pet
amont choqué et puis au delà de ça c'est
quelqu'un qui dont l'essence même est la
polémique c'est un peu les mist de
talent de sur du vent d'être agressé
dans la rue ce qui est ignoble mais mais
vous savez aujourd'hui
lorsque les opinions s'expriment
clairement
c'est ça devient un risque et
il a été menacé comme d'autres dans
notre famille politique ont été menacés
nadine morano eric ciotti dès lors que
vous vous attaquez valérie boyer dès
lors que vous vous attaquez au phénomène
de la radicalisation islamique vous
devenu une cible ou sans acceptation
juge m vous semblez quand même moins
catégorique que certains dans votre
partie sur eric zemmour est ce que pour
vous il partage on va là est-ce qu'elle
examine aujourd'hui vous le continent je
vais faire un homme de droite jonah hex
que je viens je viens de vous dire vous
me démontrer un certain nombre de
différences il y en a une autre qui est
majeur c'est que eric zemmour pour lui
prône l'union des droites ça c'est une
ligne rouge que nous n'avons nous ne
souhaitons absolument pas franchir la
discussion au ciel avec le rassemblement
national mais non contre les amène ont
il ne peut pas y avoir de discussions
entre appareils et l'air et le
rassemblement national
tout simplement parce que le
rassemblement national ne souhaite
qu'une chose c'est la mort des
républicains d'ailleurs il ferait mieux
de se préoccuper de sa propre survie
parce qu'en réalité aujourd'hui ce à
quoi on assiste et qui est tout à fait
intéressant et de ce point de vue là
eric zemmour a été un peu un
accélérateur de particules c'est que
marine le pen perd du terrain d'où
d'ailleurs la surenchère un peu affolés
laquelle elle se livre depuis parce
qu'elle se rend compte qu'elle est en
train de perdre du terrain et vous vous
ne gagnez pas est-ce qu'il est aussi un
problème pour vous ça écoute et il faut
bien voir que les républicains
la campagne commencera véritablement
lorsque nous aurons notre candidat
aujourd'hui
niro tard le 4 décembre jean leonetti
pas réglé mais quand même une
personnalité éminente de votre parti il
dit que c'est trop tard le cadre décent
mais jean leonetti est peut-être en
proie à un peu de déception parce que la
primaire avait sa faveur et comme c'est
un homme de conviction c'est peut-être
la déception qui le fait parler je crois
que si on considère que les français
vont entendre parler pendant six mois de
la présidentielle n'est ce pas suffisant
d'autant que tous les scrutins montre
qu' ils se déterminent souvent assez
tardivement et puis la stratégie de
christian jacob que je partage et de
d'avancer pas à pas pour garder tout le
monde autour de la table si vous
précipiter le mouvement si vous forcez
le le rythme vous allez créer des
déceptions vous allez créer des
rancoeurs vous allez créer la grande
autour de la laisser faire qui est de
moins en moins de monde autour de la
table un candidat unique avant le 4
décembre est ce que c'est ça la
stratégie mais mais mais si les
candidats se mettaient d'accord avant le
4 décembre
ce serait se serait tout à fait
le bonheur mais mais moi je vois des
candidats assez déterminé des candidats
talents qui ont des choses à dire ils
l'ont démontré d'ailleurs à nos journées
républicain journaux journées
parlementaires ils ont été tous
excellents donc moi j'ai compris que
vous avez envie de participer au congrès
de se jauger de cv lui s'ils se mettent
d'accord avant tant mieux un dernier mot
là dessus et les modalités précises de
ce congrès seront définis quand au sein
de votre parti robin je pense que ce
sont des questions qui vont être
examinées en bureau politique on va
tirer un peu les seniors du du
fonctionnement du congrès là ce week end
qu'est ce qui a bien fonctionné qu'est
ce qui a moins fonctionné moi je vois
quand même que ceux qui n'ont pas la
maîtrise de l'informatique c'est un peu
plus compliqué mais voilà on peut
difficilement faire autrement donc il ya
sans doute des petites choses à
améliorer et les modalités de
présentation des candidats se
détermineront
rapidement justement sur le plan
technique ceux qui ne sont pas à jour de
cotisation devront l'être avant oui les
quinze jours avant à commencer par
certains candidats ou potentiels ont
parlé de xavier bertrand parmi nous on
entends déjà certains militants à l'air
qui disent ils ont quitté le parti
comment ils font pour revenir - oui qui
crient à la trahison vous leur dites
quoi pour prôner rassemblement du
mondial il ya de l'humeur et j'ai et je
le comprends ceux qui sont toujours
restés fidèles le vivent difficilement
mais à quelque chose qui motive les
adhérents plus que tout c'est la
perspective de la victoire et si c'est
xavier bertrand ou valérie pécresse qui
tous deux ont quitté le parti qui sont
nos candidates aux lilas de est notre
candidat
je pense que ça ne posera pas de
problème parce que et a fortiori bien
sûr si c'est michel barnier eric ciotti
ou philippe juvin qui sont restés dans
le parti mais je crois que il faut
regarder de référence alors je ne me
suis pas exprimé jean touzeau pas non
non je ne me suis pas exprimé en tant
que numéro deux du parti
gg j'ai choisi j'ai choisi de me ranger
derrière le candidat que notre famille
politique retiendra je les dis
d'ailleurs en toute simplicité à chaque
candidat ce qui pour pour lesquelles
j'ai admiration et amitié mais voilà il
faut aussi il faut et à l'image de
christian jacob pouvoir être force de
l'accélérateur de rassemblement et pour
ça il faut pas prendre parti maintenant
elle et quelques mois du reste de
l'actualité ali gerba est d'abord ça te
forte hausse du prix du gaz un coup il a
annoncé plus de 12% d'augmentation dans
les prochains jours le gouvernement qui
a annoncé une rallonge du chèque énergie
d'ici la fin de l'année rallonge de 100
euros est ce que c'est suffisant à ce
que vous demandez d'autres mesures
alors cette augmentation du gaz qui est
considérable presque 60 % depuis le
début de l'année montre notre très
grande dépendance
énergétique en matière de gaz puisqu'on
apporte quasiment sans bourse donc ça
montre bien quand même que la question
énergétique on en revient toujours à ce
qui fait notre force en france c'est à
dire l'énergie nucléaire qui emmanuel
macron à si malmenés durant ce
quinquennat c'est non seulement une
énergie décarbonée une énergie abondante
une énergie qui nous donne notre
souveraineté énergétique
donc voila comme toujours avec emmanuel
macron essais gouvernement
c'est on prend des mesures et puis
ensuite on réfléchit ensuite aux
conséquences qu'elles peuvent avoir et
on pallie sa part d'échecs là en ce
moment c'est open bar ces chèques à tout
va sur le dos des générations futures on
endette à tire larigot la france c'est
choquant on sait très bien que les
dernières années de quinquennat sont
toujours prolifique en la matière mais à
ce niveau industriel là c'est du jamais
vu donc évidemment un chèque pour
compenser une politique qui a été
erratique en matière énergétique
autre sujet qui va impacter les finances
des foyers français 48 départements à
partir du 1er novembre devront circuler
avec des pneus neige
c'est une vous en pensez quoi de cette
mesure alors c'est une un dispositif qui
a été travaillé déjà depuis de
nombreuses années et qui avait été
évoqué et discuter au moment de la loi
montagne il y a des massifs montagneux
ou des imprudences aventure sur nos
routes et bloque tout le réseau routier
parce qu'ils sont pas équipés donc cette
disposition vise à corriger
cela maintenant moi j'ai toujours alerté
sur le fait qu' il fallait pas imposer
unilatéralement les équipements de neige
là où ça n'était pas nécessaire donc ça
reste quand même à l'appréciation du
préfet
qui pourra juger de la nécessité d'avoir
des pneus neige dans par exemple dans ma
circonscription qui est en moyenne
montagne il faut des pneus neige mois
chez moi j'étais pneus neige six mois de
l'année mais pour les gens qui viennent
de la plaine
quelquefois quand le temps ne l'exigent
pas il n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir des
pneus neige donc je pense que il faudra
quand même une adaptation locale à ce
dispositif
dernière question dernier sujet c'est
vraiment la crise sanitaire jean castex
qui a annoncé hier qu à partir du 15
octobre les tests ne serait finalement
plus rembourser que pour les non
vaccinés les vaccinés continueront de
voir leurs tests rembourser qu'est ce
que vous pensez cette méthode c'est la
bonne
s'ils voulaient ya des gens qui ont
utilisé le test de façon excessive et ce
à un coût non négligeable pour les
finances publiques pour le budget de la
sécurité sociale qui n'a pas besoin de
cela
il ya une forme de responsabilité
en suisse pays dont je suis frontalière
en angleterre où j'étais à la fin de
l'année dernière les tests sont payants
et je dois dire assez coûteux et il y a
même des frontaliers
je suis ce qu'ils venaient faire leur
test en france donc voyez il ya un
système qu'il fallait réguler qu'il faut
réguler moi je pense que la bonne
solution c'est la vaccination dernier
mot puisque vous parlez de la suissesse
qui a aussi un problème avec les
soignants dans un monde où louis de
soignants qui s'estiment mal payée peut
considérer et qui du coup parte vers la
suisse est ce que pour vous c'est un
réel problème dans le doubs et qu'est ce
que vous demandez olivier verrons c'est
dans le doubs et c'est sur toute la
frontière franco-suisse en savoie où le
savoy aussi basse que j'ai demandé les
ce que nous avons demandé que ma
collègue virginie d'ubs muller c'est
qu'on examine le display l'extension
d'un dispositif qui s'appelle primes vie
chère qui existent en ile de france là
où la vie est chère pour pouvoir
permettre aux soignants de vivre ce
qu'il doit vivre à proximité de leur
établissement de santé et pour éviter la
fuite des personnels soignants suisse où
ils sont mieux payés où il travaille est
semble-t-il plus facile et bien une
compensation salariale
serait la bienvenue parce que là on va
avoir un réel problème d'accès au choix
pour nos populations donc alerte sur
elle est lancé ce matin une alerte sur
ce sujet merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]